lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or a licensed professional
[Music]
hello
[Music]
it didn't break i just [ __ ] i did it
right and i was in my room i did a break
i did it right i was admiring how i did
it right look how broke look what it's
like when it's all straight like that
yeah that's kind of cool all right
look it's lifeline it's episode five
right yes it's episode five there we go
um and uh look i'll tell you this much
man uh
you'll when before we start no idea what
he's gonna do because before we started
i said i'm gonna plug my dates you did
and then i s and then what did you say
i said uh when you do that i will do
whatever i want you were trying to be
like
you were like i'm gonna
plug my dates and then implying like
just sit back and relax while i do that
and i said i could read i read how you
meant it and i said i will do whatever i
want when you do that so go ahead see
what happens i have dates coming up
i'm on the i'm going on the road
starting september here we go do you
want to do anything yet no no not yet
okay i'm tempted to do it you guys wanna
know where i'll be dude you gotta go to
chrissalia.com
um i will be in
i just had it now i'm pissed now i'm
pissed right only you have yourself to
blame i know but i do have dates coming
up um for my uh show don't not know
where you are where you're gonna be dude
atlanta september 9th
how about that you feel good about that
atlanta september 9th washington dc
september 10th stockton oakland peoria
illinois rockford illinois summon
illinois dates for some reason raleigh
north carolina october 22nd savannah
georgia denver november 5th look at this
[ __ ] boston november 12th in
jacksonville florida december 3rd
tickets right now chris leah.com and
that's what's up
that's cool man and that's what you
wanted to say about that
yeah that's cool man you got dates yeah
in cities
that's cool man thanks you're welcome
wow
i'm proud of you
thanks chilling so hard our producer is
has his [ __ ] feet up okay so i have
my shoes on right you know what you
wonder what happened when i got here
first of all i should tell everybody
what just this is like memento you're so
out of order right now start
at the right place and go do you want to
know what happened right before this yes
why is that like memento because you
start about your shoes or something
because it made me think of uh
i was thinking about that that's why
it's like momento yeah you started and
then went in another option and then
another direction and it was all out of
order i go on crazy cool tangents and it
comes
back so go ahead tell me what happened
before this um so i
we're on our way here right yeah there's
a good burrito place that i've oh
i'm pissed already but did i mention
burrito that you said burrito again dude
every single episode you've said the
word burrito at least once in the first
two minutes okay okay no not the first
one the second one i wanted to call the
last episode or the episode before that
the upswing of the burrito and you
didn't want to do that i wanted to call
both of them the upswing of the belief
and those those words all together each
one of those words is fine but those
words together like just the aesthetic
the sound of that is [ __ ] terrible
upswing of the burrito that's so bad and
i can't even believe you're my brother
and you would want that it would
definitely be a [ __ ] great you're
telling me dude all right look if you
want to make a movie called the upswing
of the bridge i know starring josh
what's his name in [ __ ] brolin no the
other one oh i want josh no but the guy
the bad guy in the hall one of the hulk
movies josh it would be josh lucas yeah
dude he would be in the upswing of the
burrito
no and the chick would be uh cameron
diaz and it would be in 2006. what's it
about
like like missing each other and then
meeting each other again and it all took
place outside of this [ __ ] mexican
restaurant
wow okay just tagged on like [ __ ]
brutal yeah but that's what they would
do they would be like can we make it a
burrito can we make it a mexican can we
involve latina it's hot can we
you know producers would do that [ __ ]
okay
when your lover's best friend becomes
your best friend's lover the upswing of
the burrito fall in love all over again
love it's tasty the the pro the problem
is is that
ever i can't even really think about
what you're saying because in the middle
of it you said upswing of the burrito
again and it like it's like nails on a
chalkboard okay it makes me [ __ ] mad
dude now that's some [ __ ] that you have
that you have to do i'm not saying it's
not because i don't want to have to do
with it so stop all right so look
this is what happened on the way in i
called
the people here and i said there's that
banging
b-word place you can say the word
burrito all of those words on their own
are fine but i said burrito and then you
said you got you got me
you word of the burrito is not good but
when i first mentioned burrito i didn't
say the upswing of it yeah yeah but it
that word oh it's triggered i was
triggered okay so listen
i got
i said hey can we order from that
burrito place it's very banging bundle
that's very banging it's very good yeah
i mean i used to live right around the
corner don't need to brag right and i
used to get it all the time the only
reason you know about this place is
because of me so i really only have
myself to blame but i'm telling
everybody that it's a banging place it's
a an amazing place it's called awaken
lake it's great now people everyone
knows where we are so
so but it's good to plug a business
right you're right you're right so we
went to we so i had it we had it one
time and then i was like can we please
can we order it again you said you were
already eaten
and the guy one of the guys here was
like sure i'll get it i'll i'll get it
right i got here okay i arrive the same
time as the postmates guy right i arrive
i walk into the building the guy's got
it he's got one thing i could tell
there's one it's a very little bag i
know it's not a big one so i know it's
my [ __ ] right it's awkward yeah awkward
yeah well it's awkward because i'm like
well that's mine but i don't know what
to do right so i get in the elevator
sure enough we go to this you know he
hits the floor right that i'm going to
go to
we're in the elevator and we're both
sitting there and i say to him hey
is that the burrito and he goes yep
and then i go then i look at him and i
say
that's mine
okay
okay and he goes [ __ ]
right yeah okay yeah and then i'm you
know we're riding for a few floors yeah
okay it's a high building we're high up
here yeah you look out here you could
see a lot l.a yeah we're up high right
got the bird's eye view exactly
we sometimes we see the back of birds i
mean it's high up right we're on we look
down and see the tops of birds it's like
that one [ __ ] movie with that guy who
plays loki that's really bad it's called
it's based on a book
who's loki oh tom hiddleston yeah oh oh
high rise yup dude he pulled it out man
ballard that's a good book dude but that
movie i've heard is bad bad movie did
you hear what i said that's a good book
yeah i read continue i read too okay
uh i read situations and right here in
this situation i knew that this guy was
my postmates guy i think you read this
one wrong but so i see him
he's got my burrito and we're going up
to the [ __ ] floor right we're getting
up to the spot where we could look down
on the birds and i look at his shoes and
he's got gucci shoes on and i'm like oh
oh priorities right right guy doing uber
eats which is fine but got gucci shoes
right so maybe not the best priorities
right okay
so
we get off on the same floor
we walk down the hallway and i'm like
well he's obviously not just going to
give it to me what if i'm lying right
well yeah that's why i was like it's
kind of awkward why say something i
shouldn't even have said something right
yeah we get off and we get to the
hallway where we gotta go i gotta go
right to get to the [ __ ] room
boom we split and go left he goes into
his apartment it's not my burrito
dun
dude it's not my burrito dude and not
only that i got so [ __ ] swooped up in
the moment that i didn't even realize
we were going to a different floor wow
you were so hot i was so sure i was like
i was like oh yeah no that's the floor
dude he was like the mentalist on me
with his [ __ ] with my food with not
my food you just walk into his apartment
yeah go like get what are we doing here
he shoots me he's so scared and i go
what about my burrito right and then he
says it's mine i said man your
priorities are so [ __ ] up and i died
looking at his shoes worst last words
[Laughter]
we're shout out to our way shout out to
i think that's what wouldn't be on
camera shout out to our [ __ ] producer
who got the worst perriers dude
[Applause]
you get the regular ones or the lime
ones right dude well what's crazy is
that there's so many other flavors that
he could have gotten that are even
better than this even the ones that are
not great you know sometimes you have to
take a chance
and that's how you discover new things
sometimes you have to take a chance and
buy 40 of them there's 40 of them in the
fridge dude there's so many in the first
two and there's only these yeah only
only these yeah um all right well this
is lifeline it is lifeline and that's
what happened to me and maybe if
somebody was in that situation with the
burrito thing they'd call in or they put
a video in or they'd write in and they
say what would i do in an awkward
elevator ride right yeah or something
like that yeah let me let me ask you to
do me a favor
stop saying burrito just moratorium on
that
good
just to the end of the episode baby
steps
i i do a lot of callbacks and i just try
it see what happens
what if i want to say it i say b word no
if you know what there's no like
punishment i'm just asking brother
brother favor i've done you a lot of
favors maybe you do me one now right
okay okay just try it i'm gonna try
my i might try it oh i mean okay
hedging's so [ __ ] hard i might try it
okay now i could feel your jealousy
though because jealousy check it out
that yup i know it's crazy first thing i
said i wish it was on camera the first
thing i said when you walked in i said
here and i reached for i said let me
take that off for you i know because i
hate it but i got the thick chains i
hate it you know what i almost did it
looks like you took it off of a bike
like the thing of a bike and somebody's
like wheels are falling off their bike
now
took it off and put it around your foot
let me tell you something about this
chain dude i almost wear a dmx shirt
with it and i thought you know what too
much
no the dm extra would have been great
changes what's wrong the dmx shirt with
the chain would have been [ __ ]
bonkers crazy because i tell you why you
want to know why because the [ __ ]
shirt had dmx on it and dmx had the same
chain on it then i would even like the
chain it would be i want a dmx shirt it
would be like the inception dmx
inception dmx inception i loved dmx so i
mean i still do rip you know but
when i was little and his [ __ ] was new i
was like that was my [ __ ] that was my
number one [ __ ] when he came out with
that song it's dark and hell is hot and
he was just like the snake the rat the
cat yeah the dog how are you going to
see him when you're living in the fall
davao
[ __ ] it up so hard so um
so anyway
so i
[ __ ] it up royally dude dmx in his
grave went like this
so um so anyway
uh we loved it right we loved it when it
came out dmx yeah yeah dude yeah but um
i almost wore that thing and i forgot i
was gonna say but i almost wore the
[ __ ] chain with the dmx [ __ ] and the
dmx had one we know because we know
because we heard you yeah no it was
great okay but so dmx is great dude
when did we do that yeah that was yeah
that was great hopefully this remember
that part when the thing would start
with the [ __ ] song uh it would start
it was a [ __ ] hopefully it is hello who
did yourself yeah yeah yeah yeah dude if
you know what i'm talking about go back
and listen to it if you don't go back
and let's do it so anyway well let's go
huh you know start all right cool let's
see what we got here lifeline what do we
got
let's get his hands hi crazy cinematics
greetings from estonia oh so asking a
little bit relationship advice from you
guys um about one and a half months ago
i met this girl and we got instantly
along so well she had very strong
connection
from both sides at least that's what she
told me i love this we did everything
together we liked each other's friends
we got along so great similar interest
everything
so a couple of weeks ago i started
feeling maybe perhaps a little bit of
like the cold side from her like
i was always telling how i miss her i
never got this back
when she went to her home country
and then one night i got pissed drunk
you know and texted some emotional [ __ ]
asking like if she even likes me anymore
and i feel like she doesn't mistake and
what's going on and of course i was
super irrational because i knew like she
might be busy doing her things
and you know if i would be sober i would
never text this kind of [ __ ] right
so she got even more colder told that
she's gonna clear her head think about
things and then when she's back then
we're gonna talk
she got back i texted her let's meet up
let's talk things through because i
regret what i told right
and basically she just texted me that
she doesn't think it's a good idea and
we should go on separate ways so my
question is
should i keep seeing how she just cut
things off like this through text
message not even willing to meet up and
speak from face to face do you think my
fears actually had some kind of basis to
it and
maybe i had some kind of hunch that
everything is not okay and maybe she
just used this opportunity to actually
break things up
so yeah i know life rips but right now
it's a little bit difficult to see that
but i know i'm gonna get over it it just
hurts right now a bit so
maybe you guys have some good advice
thank you and keep doing what you do you
guys rock
uh but i can tell he's he's hurting yeah
yeah uh i think that he was
uh right
here's the thing this this new way of
like
beginnings of relationships like there's
so much
reading
the tea leaves and trying to see through
like what the
underlying meaning of a text is
if they've read a text like sometimes
there's the receipt thing if they've
read it already
they've had it for so long who doesn't
check their phone for this long whatever
people have such different ways of
communicating and now with so many more
ways of communicating
it's even easier to be like well why is
that person reacting like that what's
this going on here what's going on with
that but i think in general when you
have a feeling
that someone is
backing off getting cold feet trying to
trying to ghost but not feel bad about
it i think there's one thing that people
do that sucks where it's like
i want to ghost this person but i don't
want to be the bad guy so i'm going to
like slowly back away and slowly respond
less and less until they just stop
trying
instead of just
being a [ __ ] solid human being and
being like hey uh i don't think this is
the greatest idea for me maybe in the
future maybe it was the wrong timing i
don't know but it's not the right thing
for me right now i'm sorry like you're a
good person but it's not going to work
out so you think she should have said
that she should have said that
his first question was do you think my
feelings were right and that my
irrational behavior just gave her an
excuse
to be like
oh well both can be right that's what
i'm saying it's all one thing yeah and i
think that yes he is right about that uh
as far as moving on and advice
what do you think i don't know i mean
well moving on well he seems to actually
understand what the
how he's feeling very well like in the
moment and also how he's going to feel
and dude life rips you know i know it
doesn't feel like it does right now but
that's exactly why life rips right
so
um he uh you know i i think that though
it's one of those things where you don't
want to the second you feel this
coldness from somebody
you gotta you can't you have to match
energies now i'm not saying it's a scary
moment yeah yeah like don't be
called back to her and you can't be like
what's going on i know i know it's not a
game that you can't be called back to
and you don't want to [ __ ] jump
they're going to be like yo am i doing
something wrong right that only pushes
them further away that's the ick right
so it's like that's something i learned
the ick is something that people say
that's nothing anybody's okay so um but
yeah i i learned it on love island dude
well that's see there's a mistake that i
learned it the mistake that you made is
watching love island but keep going dude
that's not a mistake man i've seen it
you one time you made me watch it yeah
and i was depressed for three or four
days well it i was depressed that was a
year but because yeah well
no it was great dude uh so anyway
yeah dude look this is one of those
things honestly dude you lucked out
because this was gonna happen and it's
good that you speak it's you've got a
good head on your shoulders it's sped
this [ __ ] situation up and trust me
too she's not that sh
you would have figured out she wasn't
all that great anyway like that's the
chances are that that's what was gonna
happen anyway because people say that 50
of marriages end in divorce or whatever
bro it's way more than that and also
what about just relationships the
[ __ ] chance that your relationship is
gonna work out is next to nothing
correct it's next to nice is it less
than a percent i'd love to see the math
on that dude it's next to nothing so
this dude isn't a minority he's not
weird and neither is she you guys are
the majority so congratulations on doing
it the way you're supposed to do it so
you go out there and get some drinks and
maybe [ __ ] something that tastes
really good you know what i mean it
could be mexican food don't yeah or
anything i saw it coming dude i don't
want um i don't want it so
congratulations dude he's figuring it
out i want him to [ __ ] know that he
figured it out and back in his estonia
land or whatever the [ __ ] it's called
it's just estonia yeah i mean
he also he he seems like a really good
guy he's he looks really happy but why
was he wearing wallpaper i love this
shirt you don't like a shirt i'm not
saying i didn't like it i love wallpaper
but there's some more people i [ __ ]
love no you can't say that if you say
somebody's wearing wallpaper you're
insulting you're wearing great wallpaper
yeah see nobody does that it's it's it's
look at him yeah well that's a very
honestly
that's probably the number [ __ ] top
top five shirt in estonia no doubt it's
a good shirt you can get it in that and
then also like [ __ ] uh like
uh like this color like that's what i
want right like not bright pink but like
faded pink yeah yeah yeah yeah and and
when he saw that he goes like this oh
wow yeah that's good i didn't know they
made the gray one yeah right yeah yeah i
get the gray one most people have the
pink carnation one that was a good
impression the only thing here's the
only thing the advice thing the only
thing you did wrong was
when you got drunk you were like hey
what's going on dude when you get drunk
and like you're confused about the way
someone's asking yeah the last the way
someone's acting the last thing you
should do is text that person and
inquire about the way that they're
acting that yeah
when you get drunk everybody when you
guys get drunk don't
inquire about someone's behavior that
has been confusing you yeah that is the
wrong time to do that is true dude that
is true and and and there should be a
lock if you're too drunk and you pick up
your phone yeah is that and the and the
phone senses alcohol yeah the [ __ ] shuts
down and you can't text anyone of the
opposite sex if you're straight if
you're gay it goes for the same sex the
main problem that he didn't address is
he is the bad guy that tries to break
down into the house in the original
purge and we have to talk about that oh
yeah so uh i want to address it you
gotta figure out your face because
that's who you are maybe that was her
problem maybe she realized he was the
bad guy from the purge and she's like
i'm scared i feel bad i don't want to
piss him off ethan hawke's family yeah
right all right cool well that's good we
give good pretty good advices to that
guy yeah that guy's going to be he's
going to be fine [ __ ] fine dude we
got you bro yeah
so i met this
estonian it's your boy mikey huge fan of
the podcast
i just wanted some advice on
this girl at work
she's pretty her forehead's too
comes up to me big every day
to say something
and
i preferably think oh i shouldn't do it
because you know the old saying you
don't [ __ ] where you eat
but this other kid's telling me to do it
what's the worst that could happen
so they're so blase i don't know what do
you guys think should i go for it
thanks guys so insecure the end
should i go for it
even through all thanks guys that crazy
filter even through all that you could
tell how insecure he was about asking
that last time uh uh i mean there's so
much he left out that he showed up what
kind of job is it yeah true what what
kind of work environment is it yeah like
are you a [ __ ]
surgeon or your brain surgeon scalpel
here's what i'd like to go to drinks
later here's what i think in general
about the work romance thing
would you like to [ __ ] on this brain if
you think it's really a possible
long-term relationship
maybe try it yeah if you think it's not
or no it's not
do
not do that yeah dude just avoid avoid a
void you want a doink in a [ __ ]
popeye's chicken you're gonna get fired
dude if you work at the popeye's chicken
also if you're also if you're not if you
honestly don't ever drink in any kind of
popeye's chicken even if you don't work
in the popeye's chicken because if you
you get you probably get arrested but
but you don't [ __ ] at any place where
people eat in public
that's the good rule whether you work
there or not whether or whatever ah
we're senator don't [ __ ]
any place
don't [ __ ] in any place that anyone eats
in public i'm matt dalia paid for by
matt dalia foundation um so far
so listen dude um
i agree with you also
also i would go a step further and
saying just
just don't dude if you honestly if you
really feel like a real connection and
you actually think that it's gonna be
maybe love yes it depends on what kind
of job it is if it's a career job you
know i don't know if if you are just
working at popeyes and it's not a career
job [ __ ] quit your job
i i don't think you should [ __ ] with you
eat ever dude yeah but i don't think you
should ever even comics [ __ ] comics
and [ __ ] like that's weird it's like why
but what yeah i mean so i think the
answer is just
and this there could be some kind of
permutation because you left out so many
details
that makes this not true but i think the
vast majority of times i would say
just don't do it unless you think you
actually might have like a great true
long-term relationship yeah like what
jobs would be [ __ ] like construction
site worker she comes along and that's
probably okay
if it's just like a fling you mean yeah
construction like site worker all dirty
and [ __ ] okay maybe i don't know i don't
doctors no no no no no hell no no way
dude but also that guy ain't a [ __ ]
doctor
anyone that's only listening on on audio
the guy did that kind of filter where
the nose disappears it's just a big
mouth and big eyes but also they knew
because of the [ __ ] high voice that
it was sums up i wouldn't have known oh
really yeah
so old so um but yeah dude he's just
like uh he's if he's a doctor that'd be
hilarious just like washing his hands
like this
would you like me to play some pipeliner
um
would you excuse yeah horizontal mambo
horizontal mumbo
they watch so high up dogs yeah they do
know what i mean they'd watch watch
right here
armpits you're not gonna put your elbows
in my
[Laughter]
why do they wash so high
why do they wash so high dude it's so
because of germs you know but they're
not gonna do if i ever get hit by a car
and you need to like replace my ribs
just [ __ ]
you don't even why it's fine dude i'll
get your germs it'll be all good i'll
[ __ ] them out but when is like your
bicep gonna touch
someone's insides
can i get more uh more stitching thank
you very much
thank you very much should have watched
my biceps huh
famous last words should i watch them
scalpel
all right cool
forceps forceps forceps forces
[Music]
so what's the verdict on that guy uh
don't what do you ask don't do it don't
do it unless you think that you're gonna
be in love dude yeah to be loved oh what
a feeling to be loved quit your job if
not then just [ __ ] dunk donk
doink you know yeah so we're good and
here we go
what's up chris and my name's spencer
and i'm coming from scotland beautiful
i've got a controversial one for you
today so my girlfriend always gets
really mad at me because i don't make
the bed because i don't see the point
you're just gonna be getting back in the
bed at night and [ __ ] up the sheets
anyway so i don't see the point in
making it in the morning just to unmake
it when you get back in but my
girlfriend wants me to do it because she
likes the idea of coming back to a maid
bed because it's more welcoming and more
comfortable and it's just a good habit
to start your day apparently
um so i want to know what you guys think
about that i'm going to predict your
answers chris i know that you're only
chores doing the dishes so i feel like
you're probably going gonna agree with
me
matt i think you're gonna tell me that i
should do it because
she wants me to do it and i should do it
to make her happy
um so let's see how right or wrong i am
thanks guys
wow a lot of these i really like all
these people uh first off i would say i
here's the thing
i
fully agree with him
that what's the [ __ ] point right sure
but
and i i i would agree his prediction
about what i was going to say would be
the case if i didn't also agree with her
i agree what's the point but for
whatever reason when i get in [ __ ]
bed i i feel better when it's made for
me and again i get in it and it's not
like it's a [ __ ] mess and i just lay
back where i was the last time i was in
it there's something about that and
maybe it's just been drilled in my head
from like
because my [ __ ] parents told me to do
it and [ __ ] and like i got used to it
and that's associated with like some
kind of sense of order with making my
bed but so it's weird i agree with them
both yeah it's like what the [ __ ] is the
point i'm just gonna [ __ ] this up again
but
later when it's time to go to bed i'm
always like i should have [ __ ] made
this thing sometimes i'll even do that
thing this thing not that thing like
anybody else [ __ ] does this but i'll
like make it at like 11 p.m
leave the room to like brush my teeth or
whatever the [ __ ]
and then come back and i still can get
that feeling wow that's really crazy
you're a crazy person okay everyone is
everyone has a little bit of not crazy
i'll tell this guy first of all you are
sebastian stan and he is beautiful he's
a beautiful guy okay yeah you're very
good you're looking you're actually i
would say you're better looking than the
sebastian stan
yeah maybe okay so um
crazy he just got out of the shower and
[ __ ] threw a shirt on and did this
video it was beautiful here to drive
what i'm just saying so so listen dude
um
making the bed is
for the birds do you know what i mean i
don't ever want to do it i won't do it
right i only do dishes and sometimes
kristen even though we made the rules i
just do dishes i just fill the
dishwasher up i just unload the
dishwasher that's my only chore
sometimes she'll be like why'd you leave
your socks there and i'll say does this
look like dishes you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] no i'm not yep because i stick
to the rules and i abide by the rules
and anything else that comes my way i go
like this can you drink out of that
does that fit in the dishwasher so
english
dishwasher um and then she goes like
this chris and i say
i'm just playing by the rule
who made those rules her
why did she make her she was like she
was like you just do the dishes and i'll
do everything else and i go like i say
yeah but dude i said this is the worst
part she's like exactly but so you've
worn her down so much that she
expects so little of you be on my side
i'm not though dude this is [ __ ] your
[ __ ] you're my brother
you're [ __ ] dude bad brother
you a siren you
are [ __ ]
no
and that's it so here's that also my
advice to him is you are [ __ ] i also
agree with the fact that it really does
feel nice to get into a nice bed right
but guess
what
she can do it if she wants to so badly
is it worth
is it worth doing it
during the day is that worth the feeling
at night and i think it comes down to if
you're a man the answer is no if you're
a female the answer is yes you know why
because females love things
and they love
things as in things to do
they wear big extra
sweatshirts because it's like ooh you
know what i mean
which i'm doing right now i know but and
i have this i have a question for you
i have a question for you yeah
you ready what
what's the question you have a question
for me i can see it
am i a female
no well i don't know you know i i know i
know you're not but it's worth it to me
to do it even though i agree with them
that what's the point that little the 10
or 15 seconds it takes
is worth it
when it's time to get in bed it doesn't
take different successes how about when
you get it
no no that's that's right that was the
next thing
is [ __ ] you don't need to do the
corner over you don't need to be martha
stewart no no no no throw the sheets
back up dude all right well me in the
middle somewhere i guess so but it's
just it's not worth the feeling what
this guy agrees with me on is it's not
worth the feeling of getting in the
[ __ ] [ __ ] at night like uh that cool
nice feeling that feeling is nice but
it's not worth doing it in the daytime
also why doesn't she do it because what
she goes out for the day
he probably wakes up he probably wakes
up late later yeah which is true if you
wake up last it's your assignment [ __ ]
all that dude just don't make the bet
dude
[Music]
no what is that we win we win at that no
dude you lost okay you lost you agree
with me that it's a good feeling it is a
good feeling but it's not worth the
effort of making the bed let me ask you
how much effort is it truly to make a
[ __ ] bed
one bed
out of what ten no no how like how much
time okay
so you gotta [ __ ] take the sheet you
got to take the undersheet you got first
of all the worst part is the first part
you got to figure out where the [ __ ]
little thin sheet is it's always tucked
in in the back under the [ __ ] [ __ ]
for some reason like somebody came in
like a little troll came in the middle
of night and just like let's hide this
they'll never know it what's happening
when you go to sleep there's a [ __ ]
tornado every night no why are the
sheets all over the place dude are you
kidding me sheets twist and turn they go
nuts
they do you know they do and then they
[ __ ] you got to figure out where they
are you got to figure out which one goes
on top of what and you so you put this
one you got to tuck it in on the [ __ ]
you got to get the other blanket you got
to tuck it in and then you got to get
the comforter do it make it so it's all
even because guess what dude he can't
half-ass do it
he can't have this dude because if he
does have it do it gets which he does
you didn't even really try no then you
can say yeah i did if you don't like the
way i did it then maybe you can do it
but this is the way i do it that's a
compromise that's a good
that is a good
this is the way i do it
this is the way he makes it
he doesn't fold the corners
more
no okay
um all right cool so we figured it out
thanks very much
here we go another one okay uh-uh you
want to read her me i'll read it
hey matt and chris love the podcast and
congratulations
i have a problem that i'm not sure what
to do about it that's bad grammar but
it's okay i get really black i get
really blacked out almost every time i
drink and i usually wake up not knowing
what happened well there's two more
paragraphs but we could stop it right
there and give advice but go ahead but
that's not the part i'm concerned about
oh
soon over there i kill dogs i almost
always get a message from a girl or find
out a different way that oh jesus that i
did the horizontal mambo with them
but i have no remembrance it's foreign
wow i have no remembrance i hope i put
my friend in his glove because i'm too
young to have kids
why is he [ __ ] dartanian
anyways signed i i i guess i'm have i'm
asking for advice on how to make this
happen less often and how to handle the
conversations with these girls do i tell
them i don't remember or just keep it to
myself any advice with help uh okay
there's a conspiracy just
stop
[ __ ]
drinking so much [ __ ] yeah how are you
drinking so much that you're black out
but also you can get [ __ ]
[ __ ] bricked up but also how many
times does this happen
drink less dude yeah [ __ ] you i've never
had anything we don't know how old he is
we don't know how what the [ __ ]
happening he's too young to have kids i
guess i'm asking for advice on how to
make this happen less often how to make
it happen even once is like oh my god
that's horrifying dude
so uh he doesn't know that he's doing
the horizontal mambo because he blacks
out and has sex and then the chicks text
him later like well that was crazy how
we doinked and he goes
what
yeah this guy has no idea dude he has no
idea hey guy
you don't know what happened
stop drinking yeah you gotta how do i
dude get or get boxers that say you know
please help don't do this i don't know
what's happening right like put a
post-it on your dick do not use yeah or
like a [ __ ] tattoo something next to
your [ __ ] shaft no get a chastity
belt have i been drinking get a chastity
bite don't pull lever and give the key
to your friend
[Music]
right yeah hey [ __ ] you get so many
joker hey man i'm gonna need
yeah
yeah listen dude you gave me the key
freezing [ __ ] you you [ __ ]
yeah and then the next day his [ __ ]
friend's like man you [ __ ] and he's
like i didn't call you yeah that was no
dude i did not do that yeah i mean this
is a dangerous thing dude dangerous stop
drinking times like this just stop
drinking i say
i say a lot of the things during times
like these is one of the things i say
you know what i mean i used to okay
relax i used to drink so much and i'm
it's not because i got sober or anything
i didn't go to a which is totally a
viable route if you need to get sober i
just for me it was like i just i
actually got really sick in a separate
thing and then i had to stop drinking
because of that and then by the time i
was better i was like i don't even like
to do this anymore how drunk can you be
see i was in the middle of a point oh i
thought you were done nope cool i guess
it just got boring there
slam uh
i'm just saying it it isn't that [ __ ]
fun to drink
okay so people don't do it because it's
fun they do it because they have to you
know no i think a lot of times they'll
do it because they want to have a point
where they want to feel loose they want
to [ __ ] do things like this but jesus
is going way too far dude this is going
way too far how many [ __ ] times have
you blacked out and had sex with someone
let's put it this way it's at least
three right because if it was one it
wouldn't have it wouldn't be a problem
if it was two he wouldn't write in about
it it's at least three which means it's
probably above four yeah yeah one one is
like
you must learn the lesson after that yes
you have to one is oh i hope this
doesn't happen again two is shut
everything down dude yeah defcon5 yes i
black out when i drink and i don't can i
have no idea that's right that is a dan
that is a scary thought actually yeah
but also uh
are these are they playing you you know
maybe there's like a [ __ ] group
there's a conspiracy how many times look
at it from all angle dudes that's one of
my good things no see now he's got now
you're giving him an excuse to be like
you know what maybe it's yeah
and get plastered and then more texts
later
get stop drinking
here are your three possibilities stop
drinking drink a lot less and keep tabs
on yourself as you are going which is
the hardest one or three get a [ __ ]
chastity belt and give the key to
your best friend or mother or father
okay or whoever what about when we were
talking and you said it's not that fun
to drink and then i said yeah but maybe
he's not drinking because he people he's
not drinking because he's funny he's
drinking because he has to and then i
started to say that's why i dance and it
was gonna be really funny but what
happened was you cut me off and started
saying something and my line got drowned
out
so what about that
how does that make you feel because for
me right i feel blood boiling but it's
fine because of my brother and i love
you yeah yeah yeah i also am in this
space where it's like i want to be like
don't do those kinds of things you know
yeah so how do we combat that well first
i would say
welcome to my world right because that's
what you do to me in a vin diesel movie
in a vindicate to my world
permit dude i mean i mean the vin diesel
fastened anybody that used to listen to
my podcast knows i have a whole hang up
with vin diesel fast on the green you're
an actor right you are a [ __ ] actor
spoiler the one thing you have to do
is be able to speak want a drag race and
he
can't
say words in a way
that people understand it's not easy
being dragged and so why is he
the most famous [ __ ] actor
the world is upside down and backwards
and his stardom is proof the korean
guy's here
is that him as kermit yeah he's fast and
furious fast and green hey guys kermit
it's about friend it's about family
it's about family i said karma at the
venue stepped on it three times
the vid yeah
so bad dude i'm glad we i'm going to be
see that's what i do i give respect my
dance [ __ ] should have been like oh yeah
that was funny but you didn't but i give
it respect and that's fine you're always
funny i didn't think that that was that
funny yes wait what
wow dude you're always funny i didn't
think that one was particularly funny i
gauged it as it was happening i thought
i'm gonna keep going okay do i feel bad
no but do i promise to not
you know
promise to be aware of it moving forward
yes
because i'm a good brother it's not easy
being in a drag race you ever see the
movie boiler room yeah there's this one
part where he it's like at the end when
it's all crumbling uh the whole thing
and him and giovanni or bc are in the
stairwell outside their office yeah i
know it and he says
[ __ ] seth jesus his name is seth and he
goes
[ __ ]
oh wow okay the one thing you need to do
is say things and he's not doing it
right yes correct
and he's also why do people act like
he's a big muscular guy when he's just
kind of an italian guy fat guy well no
he used to be legit jack but he's a fat
[ __ ] fat cue ball guy so
[ __ ]
dick
you know i mean i i don't know what this
is about family though okay next one
can i add to i don't want to make a
habit of doing this but i quit i want to
add
to your advice which is he should check
his medication
he could be taking meds that make you
black out that's something i learned
interesting i learned it the hard way so
i learned it the hard way dude if you
take adderall for any reason and then
you drink you're done you block it
it's way easier to black out deeper
yeah that's good to know no that's good
good to know thank you for living the
[ __ ] mistake that he doesn't have to
uh even though he is um
so uh yeah that's the advice we have for
you check your medication and also all
the stuff that matt said and then mostly
just mainly the stuff i said
if none of those things get a chance to
build thank you
wow would be positive would be
[ __ ] 100 in a 90s movie and a [ __ ]
huge star and then the 2000s would come
and she would have a kid and quit acting
go ahead
yeah hi guys
sue
my problem is um
that i just moved to a new neighborhood
and
um and by just i mean a year
and um my neighbors are great but it's a
small neighborhood like five blocks by
the water
um i'm on the east coast but
five blocks but it's it's small so you
gotta be like careful with situations
so this one neighbor she's across the
street and her voice is so awesome yeah
she has dogs i have dogs great
um but um
she lets them out
early like early like
six yeah and change 6 30 and i wake up
early my husband and i we wake up early
but like her dogs are out barking at
like 6 30 for like 20 minutes straight
and maybe i didn't want to wake up at 6
30. i usually don't want to wake up at 6
30. i'm looking for like seven plus
yeah
how do i talk to her
and not create a problem
because this woman's been living here
for 35 years she's an older lady she's
like probably almost 70. of course if we
do that how do you bring
uh that option
please don't say spin moves involved in
the answer because i don't think that's
going to work with this i honestly i and
thank you bye-bye i agree with her i'd
agree with her on that this isn't a spin
move mentality you do have to have the
spin move mentality because that's a
that's a defiant i'm me sort of
thing
that that we need to live so
she needs okay you're pissing me off no
but we need to
we need to a sprinkler we need to
we need to we need to be clear this is
not a spin move situation she was clear
and she was right she shut it down
before you even [ __ ] went there you
[ __ ] she understands spin move mentality
that's why you don't
i do i just don't like that it's your
advice for every single single thing
it's not this isn't it
85 no no leading up to this definitely
don't work for the drunk guy okay
hey he's gonna get injured yeah and then
she's still
um so anyway so crash dude okay so
so wow he did a spin move and fell
anyway so out of breath
i don't remember okay okay
[ __ ] yeah dude
okay uh
so
i do wake up really early and even
bragging i wake up early
it
that would bother me even if i was a
wait already awake dude yeah right now
that is
it's a time of peace that early if
you're up it's got to be peaceful and
most people aren't up there still
[ __ ] sleeping
you'd be like
i see those [ __ ] dogs
wow dude came early okay
premature ejaculation
all right so those [ __ ] dogs that
[ __ ] lady it is a universally
niche niche to do that you cannot do
that okay knit knit yeah no no i agree
so the way to talk to her is from a
place of
look we all already know that this is
the wrong thing to do if you start with
look you know you mean business yeah
it's like you we already all know
that this is that's wrong yeah right
like
look you know i know everybody in these
five blocks knows this is shitty to do
yeah okay so that's not what you say
that's your tone what you say can be you
know you're you you put it in your own
phrasing but like i think the the the
way to approach it is just like uh we
all know this is not right i don't know
what's up with everybody else why they
don't bring it up maybe they're afraid
of you i don't know this is the tone
these are not your words yeah but it's
like
wait maybe
45 minutes like just a little bit longer
if you need to let them out to pee maybe
back in just for a little bit but like
that's really early and i'm sleeping and
i think a lot of people also are
sleeping but like
come on what something's got to give
here this is just this is [ __ ] you're
you're being rude it is rude yeah yeah
okay i have advice
well that's what the show's for so go
ahead get a pet bear
leave it outside they they won't make
any noise and then the [ __ ] dogs that
there's no way that 70 yard line is
gonna let dogs outside with a bear next
door outside did you think about how
often you'd have to feed the bear what
you would do with the bear with the
bears inside
problems on top of problems sometimes
the only way to solve a problem is to
add a problem this is okay
that
is not only the worst advice
that we've given on this show
it is the worst advice i've ever heard
and also
and also it is the worst advice possible
to give to anyone about any single thing
no way get a bear dude get a [ __ ]
bear play hardball dude
hi i'm chris matthews welcome to
hardball be like that you know what just
say that to her call up
hello hi i'm chris matthews and this is
hardball click oh by the way open your
window click and open the window and
there's a bear out there
and the [ __ ] dogs will never go
outside again dude sometimes the only
way to solve a problem is to add another
problem i'm crystal lee and this message
was paid for by the chrysalia foundation
and dude i also dude
um
why are you only living in a
neighborhood that's five blocks i've
never even heard where is that it sounds
peaceful it's i think it's not peaceful
there's dogs outside it's by the water
dude have you ever seen fear of thy
neighbor
no it's not discovery plus holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude dude
you only watch shows
no about like real people who like
committed a murder right yeah yeah
that's all you watch
i didn't even know that but i knew that
shark tank oh oh and then love island
and love island so you got the worst
taste on the planet that's not true no i
also tried to watch [ __ ] what's it
called that uncharted movie with tom
holland and mark wahlberg last night oh
so you got the worst taste ever guess
when i stopped watching it 30 minutes
before it ended that's the most
disrespectful time to stop watching
that's true you did it it was so bad
dude sometimes it was so [ __ ] bad the
only way to salvage the time you've
wasted is to leave at the most
disrespectful possible moment dude i
walk out in theaters right before the
ending sometimes sometimes at boring
dinners i say and you know what actually
happened to me today
and then [ __ ] leave because that's so
disrespectful well that's rude to people
you know what tell me about your day and
then i leave that's rude to people dude
whose presence you're currently in i
don't want to
hurt the people's feelings that are
around me i want to like disrespect
damian chazelle or something if they
created the if they created a film
school major if they created what is
that that's the [ __ ] guy that taught
the first man in la la land she's
filming school
so i'm drunk
so uh no i wanna i wanna i wanna if if
the person created the the thing that
makes me feel disrespected did you need
to absolutely create a [ __ ] another
problem for that person
and you think that that stopping the
movie 30 minutes before it ends is the
way to go dude and leaving a dinner
after you ask them how their day's been
is [ __ ] disrespectful because they're
wasting my time with boring as dinner
yes dude figured it out getting a bear
is the [ __ ] best way to combat
barking dogs they won't let the dogs
outside you win dude i mean dude fear
thy neighbor is a crazy show people have
gotten killed for way less than this
dude oh yeah i saw that i saw an episode
where i mean because this woman is you
got to fear for your life dude this is
because that's crazy this lady right
here that called okay because this other
lady is putting dogs out there doing
what she wants and guess what been doing
what she wants and all of a sudden uh
you know uh amanda who's whatever this
lady's name is moves in right and she
[ __ ] gets there and now the old lady
is like i can't do what i've been doing
for 40 years trust me dude this lady
isn't going to be putting up with that
and she's going to either buy a gun or
use her husband's gun or use her dead
husband's gun because she's got nothing
to live for
anymore of [ __ ] no i'm not i'm but
i'm not meaning to right i'm not meaning
to this is real life i've watched fear
thy neighbor and then come up with a
solution that's my main
because bro i saw one where this [ __ ]
guy moves into a neighborhood and his
kids leave toys on the other guy's lawn
and the guy mobilized his family started
doing army drills out in the front yard
and then shot the dad dude i'm sorry i
need to hear you say that again i i got
lost because that's too crazy so do it
again in the show fear thy neighbor
there was an episode where a family
moves in and that family leaves their
toys on another man's yard and so the
other guy who lives there
gets upset mobilizes his family starts
doing army drills in the front yard
to scare the other family and then the
guy
shoots the dad all cause of toys that's
how it started dude yeah all cause of
toys so i'm saying watch fear thy
neighbor come up with some solutions get
a bear is that person in jail yeah good
or they killed themselves i don't
remember they always end up killing
themselves or going to jail
get a bear
are
completely gone i know it's sad it's
crazy dude and we're all crazy but it's
just like people always wonder
yeah sorry people always wonder like how
could somebody be like that in their own
private lives like how could somebody
have said that to me how could somebody
have thought that but what i said it's
like i know do you [ __ ] understand i
know how absolutely demented every
single [ __ ] person is like why don't
you keep that knowledge in your mind i
know you've heard stories like that i
know keep that in your head nothing
makes sense nothing ever makes sense
nobody does nobody nobody's actions make
sense
uh it's so hard not to someone else yeah
it's so hard but you forget that and
then also like you ever catch yourself
like i'm trying to limit the amount of
times a day i say why did that person do
that good job i mean you're on the right
track yeah because it's like you they're
that person you have nothing to do with
them yeah you have no idea what's going
on in their mind you don't know what
kind of chemicals they have in their
mind and what makes up their brain not
to mention what [ __ ] happened to them
yes exactly
so watch out for this lady because you
don't know how what makes up her mind
but also don't get a bear you know let's
go baby get a bear that's called
escalation and i don't think you want
that
all right anymore
i'm matt and chris i'll keep it short
sure my question is
is a like a flirt
or is it
a show of support a like i've been with
my boyfriend now for
just about three years
and he is a serial liker
it doesn't matter if it's a family photo
or an ass pic he just likes them all
and he says that it's his way of showing
support because he likes it when people
like his photos and i've talked with my
friends about it i've talked to my guy
friends my girlfriends and i just want
to know is a like a flirt or is it
nothing and i'm being over dramatic
i
feel strongly about this okay what's up
a like
is not
a flirt
okay
it's not what that is you know what's a
flirt you know what's flirting flirting
if you think liking someone's [ __ ]
photo on instagram is flirting you are
the worst in the world at florida
titties pick an ass pic
that's not flirting dude how was that
okay well she's i guess what okay yeah
that is what she asked what do you what
what well i guess i guess what i what i
what i took it as is
you only own 50 of what you say because
the other people receive the fifty
percent of it right so if i am out there
liking chicks asses and titties on
instagram okay well you know it's
different for me because i have a
[ __ ] fan base but like if you're just
someone that doesn't have a fan base and
your friends all see this guy liking we
have one friend that does this nonstop
we're not going to mention his name
because but we know someone who it's
like
he likes oh yes yes yes yes um and
comical degree yeah and he and and it's
like
you know that becomes a thing if you're
if you're a family man and you're doing
that [ __ ] yeah right and you're like
yeah but it's just about support but is
that there's still other people out
there that are your friends that are
going to be like the [ __ ] is this guy
doing but that's not flirting no no it's
not flirting so maybe i i
no if if i like
someone's picture it's not necessarily
flirting you're right
okay there's i'm going beyond the
question and what we do here is
sometimes i think very deep so let's go
yes let's go and i go beyond that
there's a button there to indicate that
you like a thing
so
if you see something that you like
why not
hit the button right that is so easy to
hit
to express your like yeah it's not like
he's poking them on facebook
or writing them a [ __ ]
a drool emoji right you're not you're
not commenting like oh man hey sexy
you're not i mean if he's doing that
if he's doing that then that's flirting
oh man he should just comment holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] bricked up city that will be
flirting where you from bricked avenue
holy [ __ ]
did are you kidding me that cleavage
makes me go bracket cat cat right okay
so thinking through all the way to the
[ __ ] end though if he's flirting by
liking photos
he's
the worst
ever on the planet of flirting now what
we do is we go beyond the question and
if you're insecure about that which i
don't think is necessarily a bad thing i
get it if you don't want your boyfriend
to be doing that that's a different
thing and i've actually heard women make
this complaint about their boyfriends or
husbands or whatever that they will
and men are always like you know this is
like a common male female back and forth
that i've
yeah heard actually be an issue with
people so what i just said is that what
you just said no no no i'm asking you
what what is
oh oh oh what's she saying like my oh is
it a flirt or like there or like it it
riles up the female makes them jealous
something like that yeah yeah yeah
that's for sure something right yeah no
doubt i guess we're kind of saying the
same thing right yeah right right right
um
yeah i mean i don't know i think it's uh
but also if here's here's the main main
main thing
if
you
the woman submitting this to us have an
issue with it or it makes you feel
insecure or whatever and you've
expressed this to your partner and he's
just like ah [ __ ] it i still want to
like it like yeah that's weird if he has
the spin move mentality on that that's
bad he should just just because i guess
but i liked it if you've expressed this
to him and he's just still doing it like
that's weird like he should just stop
it's so easy just here's the thing just
as easy as it is to do it to express a
like about something that is in one way
or another pleasant for you to look at
or think about whatever it's also just
as easy if not easier to not do that
yeah and so what's more valuable to this
guy expressing to some like acquaintance
or stranger that that he likes what
is in the photo that the person that he
might may or may not even really know
wow presenting or
making your [ __ ] wife or girlfriend
whoever
feel better sometimes you just speak the
truth dude sometimes you break [ __ ] down
and the latter is way way way more
important one would [ __ ] hope yeah
so the issue is less is it a flirting
thing or not the issue is more why does
the guy have to [ __ ] do it if he
knows you don't like it the [ __ ] up
with that well does she not like it we
don't even really know but we're
assuming right we should assume yeah
you're really sm that was good that was
good advice i'm really smart too oh okay
okay so the bear thing that's
interesting how you gave me a compliment
but more or less just kind of cloaked it
in good things about you thank you
no
no to that okay i think we have time for
one more let's do it let's do it again
dude
hey chris and matt my wife's 30th
birthday is coming up and i really want
to make it big worst
wall display of all time dude [ __ ] so
high up baseball [ __ ] diamond and a
shelf too high
and a white wall go ahead
hey chris and matt my wife's 30th
birthday is coming up and i really want
to make it big and special for her yeah
so please let me know how many spin
moves you think i should do that day
and
uh what else you think i should plan for
you know big surprises for her to make
sure that this is um you know her her
biggest and best birthday ever
thank you
wow good cute that you're very cool
about that yeah
here's the thing what if he was okay
never mind not even funny what i could
recommend in terms of specifics doesn't
matter you have to think about what she
likes dude the number one thing to do
dude okay here we go no that oh i'm
agreeing with oh good dude that's what
my chicks are always doing that [ __ ]
dude it's a deeper but they are they're
like they're like guess what
what for your birthday we're going to
creighton barrel you're like this is for
you
yeah i got your friends together and
she's inviting johnny i don't give a
[ __ ] yeah i mean i haven't had that
experience that sounds shitty though i'm
just saying though chicks love it guess
what we're doing what we're going to
[ __ ] montana you saw [ __ ]
yellowstone right right okay yeah it's a
deeper like saw deeper sir deeper for
decades
i can't really relate to that but i can
relate to this [ __ ] guy
the pressure
of what do i do for the big birthday and
he wants to make it a big deal he wants
to make her feel [ __ ] good but he
doesn't know what to do all you got to
do
is you got to be like a hunting dog you
got to be like a pi you got to sniff out
and by now i should hope there's a
[ __ ] laundry list of things that you
can think of immediately when i say this
but sniff out the things that you know
she likes and just make a list of it
like 15 20 [ __ ] things and then
whittle it down what are like two or
three of them that i can really focus on
and try to
have her experience in some way or
another on her birthday i mean this is
stupid but like does she like museums
does she like
chicks love music whatever
i love museums take her to a museum
already for real okay
take her to the [ __ ] moma oh my god
she'll [ __ ] freaking out about my museum
i did no i mean dude are you kidding me
if you take a chick to a museum you got
to bring towels i mean they're insane
they love it dude it's the most romantic
thing you all you got to do is you know
what i think the artist was doing here
if you say you know what i think the
artist was doing here she will [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
the back of your hair
i mean this [ __ ] will be [ __ ] part of
the center for take it to a museum you
got it we figured it out dude i mean but
go ahead but museum is 100 dude i mean
that's pretty much it if you
just figure out and think about
the things that she likes right
and all you have to do is come up with
like a cute
way or some kind of plan
an order of things to do all that built
around
specifically tailored around
her and what she likes it doesn't have
to be
see i think this is where people get
caught up they get caught up on this
thing of like it has to be special but
special is not a thing it's like a it's
fairy dust it disappears when you reach
out and try to get it you need to just
do the things that she likes that's it
even if that's
[ __ ] just sitting on the couch
watching [ __ ] stupid movies do the
things that she likes yeah and also dude
um
like a picnic is a really good idea
you [ __ ] idiot you know
like a maybe if you take up not maybe
that's another museum idea dude if you
take a [ __ ] picnic if you take a
blanket and a basket and two sandwiches
and you just walk two or three blocks to
a [ __ ] grassy area and say sweetie
sit down for your 30th i know [ __ ] gets
crazy and you might have wanted to do
something insane but i want it to take
some time to where it's just us and we
could have a moment for ourselves and
let you know that i love you and guess
what i'm going to love you until you're
40. and beyond but i'm saying
the decade of this decade and i love you
now take a bite of this turkey mustard
sandwich i made you that's soggy and
then do it like this where they do it
like this
and then kiss each other and [ __ ]
taste each other's mustard sandwiches
and do and do the horizontal mambo on
the [ __ ] grassy knoll
back and to the left what you just
described
is mad depressing
do you know what i mean
yeah but
again we're doing it for her she'll love
it dude and then and then while you're
doing it in the middle of it if she's
not feeling it just be like you know
what we should have done the museum huh
[Music]
[Music]
that's [ __ ] so stupid
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
this is
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] dude i'm hot we're done dude
[ __ ] all right dude listen yeah
okay we had a great time here
so yeah go to uh what do we do no here
look atlanta september 9th washington
september 10th i'm going to be in
stockton oakland peoria rockford
illinois raleigh savannah denver
cheyenne november 6 boston november 12th
december 3rd i'm going to be in
jacksonville and that's just the
beginning i'm coming new york i'm coming
texas i'm coming everywhere just uh you
know those are the ones for now and if
you have a [ __ ] question for us you
need advice we need good advice we were
on a [ __ ] role today we gave some
good [ __ ] if you
need some for yourself
send in a video uh and if it's super
dark and secret you already know you can
write it in but uh preferably it's video
you can put something over your head
like the one [ __ ] guy yeah the
instagram filter yeah exactly uh so uh
link in the description below or go to
watchlifeline.com
to figure out how to do that thank you
and we love you subscribe and like and
also give people advice in the comments
activate that algorithm baby
subscribe and like subscribe and like
subscribe and like subscribe and like
okay good yes thank you great
[Music]